we begin today with extremely sad news I
never thought I would have to say this I
never thought it would come to this but
the great Erick's wall well has ended
his campaign for president sois well was
our last hope he was the only light left
shining in the dark he was the
lighthouse on stormy shores guiding us
home and now that light is out and we
are floating drowning in the dark ocean
yeah I remember only a few days ago my
my six-year-old son came up to me and we
had a very real conversation he said
daddy it feels like there's no hope in
the world it feels like we're all doomed
like we are just spinning chaotically
through the void of space with no reason
or purpose or destination in mind and I
looked at him and I said I said we do
have hope we have swallow and he looked
at me and he said what is SWA well and I
said stop talking back go to your room
what am I supposed to say to him now
that swallow has ended am I supposed to
say to him oh never never mind you're
right there is no purpose in life there
is no hope we are doomed I you know SWA
well left a campaign that excited the
nation a campaign that at its zenith
polled at 0.5% how could you leave
something like that when when when when
so many people literally literally tens
and tens of of people wanted this man to
be president yet he still drops out so I
just want to begin as a matter of
respect with a moment of silence for
Erick's well well and his campaign and
also the future of the nation a moment
of silence please thank you
okay you know the interesting
is that I think Eric SWA whales audience
oftentimes what he would give speeches
his audience somehow I think sense they
had a premonition
maybe his audience was as was as sort of
prophetic as well well himself
they had a premonition that this moment
would come because sometimes as I think
very respectfully beautifully they would
give him moments of silence during his
speeches like maybe you remember this
moment but I will always be real with
you I will be bold
without the bold my wife and I we fight
insurance companies I bold without the
bold or bold without the bull bull
without the bold I'm not really sure
what he said there but it was it was
very profound and to hear that moment
sounds afterwards just immense respect
for this man who has unfortunately left
us all to die okay well what we actually
are going to begin to with today is is I
want to talk about why well I think
where this is going to lead is why you
should consider homeschooling which is
something I've talked about many times
there are about 80,000 chapters to this
particular book about why you should
homeschool rather than send your kids to
public school today we're gonna focus on
just one chapter that is this the
largest teachers union in the country
just came out to passionately defend
abortion and we're gonna get to that in
a moment but first here's an alarming
statistic for you as we're beginning the
show with alarming things then how about
this over 75% of Americans are
dangerously deficient in omega-3 levels
if you're experiencing joint pain
chronic inflammation lack of
concentration and weight gain chances
are you're probably one of them no
matter your age your height your weight
or gender omega-3 fatty acids are vital
to your overall health and considered a
miracle pill by many experts they're
clinically proven to improve mood your
memory your brain cardiovascular health
you name it it improves it but many of
the top sellers simply do not contain
enough omega-3s to note to to to bring
about noticeable therapeutic results if
you want to feel the benefits instantly
then you need to try Omak
three ultra-pure it's the only
game-changing omega-3 supplement on the
market
it's 94% pure omega-3 or Omax three is
clinically tested certified and
sustainably sourced so that means it's a
hundred percent safe for you and your
family Oh max is offering my listeners
50% off a one month supply of Oh max
three plus free shipping and plus you
get that 60-day money-back guarantee
just go - Oh max health.com
enter code Walsh today to take advantage
of the savings here which you're going
to want to do that that's om ax
health.com and enter code walls for 50%
off a one-month supply Oh max calm oh ma
XCOM enter code walls today 50% off a
one month supply again you're gonna want
to go do that all right
Alexandre de Sanctus over at national
review and she's one of my favorite
writers by the way she's really on top
of the abortion issue a great pro-life
advocate she has this story I'm gonna
read the first paragraph or two to you
says over the weekend the National
Education Association adopted a new
business item declaring its support for
quote the fundamental right to abortion
under a row v Wade the NEA is the most
influential teachers union in the United
States with more than three million
members it's also the nation's largest
labor union of any kind here's more from
the document says the NEA will honor the
leadership of women non-binary and trans
people and other survivors who have come
forward to publicly name their rapists
and attackers in the growing
international me - movement furthermore
the NEA will include an assertion of our
defense of a person's right to control
their own body especially for women
youth and sexually marginalized people
the NEA vigorously opposes all attacks
on the right to choose and stands on the
fundamental right to abortion under roe
v wade the statement goes on to assert
that this new stance is necessary
because quote the most misogynistic
forces under trump want to abolish the
gains of the women's right movement and
it goes on there so there you have it
this is not a shock of course we know
that the NEA is a rapidly left-wing
organization has been
forever still the NEA has affiliates in
every state it has as was mentioned
there three million members three
million and these are people that are
teaching our children it's not just that
they have a left-wing bias but that
they're comfortable they feel obliged
even to be so blatant and so loud and
proud about their bias so think about
that for a moment if this is what the
NEA says publicly what do you think
these teachers and by that I mean the
true believers in the organization the
true left-wing believers and they're not
all true believers all three million of
them but what do you think the true
believers are saying to your kids when
nobody else is around and when they
don't have any other adult supervision
what do you think they're doing with
your kids psychologically it should go
without saying
I think it needs to be said anyway
teachers have immense power that's one
of the reasons why I'm an advocate for
homeschooling because the teachers have
such power that it's just is that power
you really power over your kids
specifically is that are you really
going to trust another person with that
kind of power if teachers are given a
receptive attentive mind then they are
going to have immense power over that
mind and here's the problem if our kids
go to school we need for them to have
receptive and attentive minds if they're
not receptive if they're not attentive
then school is a total waste of time and
there's no point in even going and it is
therefore a waste of time for many kids
and there are a lot of good teachers who
have to deal with the fact that a lot of
the kids in there just aren't receptive
to anything to anything they're saying
and it's just it's it's a difficult
situation but as for the kids who have
in a sense the right mentality that of
receptiveness and attentiveness now you
know for those kids we need teachers to
be extremely responsible and honest and
respectful and how they handle those
minds which they have been given for
molding and many teachers no doubt are
responsible and honest and and they have
integrity and they're respectful in how
they deal with those minds I had some
teachers like that myself growing up but
listen if all three million members of
the NEA were responsible and honest then
there's no way the NEA would be the left
wing extremist organization that it is
now I mean it may not represent
ideologically everybody in the
organization but it does represent a
significant chunk of it if it didn't
then it wouldn't be a left-wing
organization so you have to think about
that that there are that there are
therefore plenty of actual left-wing
radicals in that organization they're
the ones who have this power over your
child's mind and just think of what they
can do what they do in fact do with the
receptive at attentive minds that
they're given for molding it's a
chilling thing to contemplate
and that's why I think we should all at
least consider the possibility that
maybe we just can't trust I mean you you
may hopefully if you send your kid to
public school there are some teachers at
your kids school that you do trust but
there's no way you could trust all of
them especially if it's a large school
you can't even know all of them now of
course you could ask the question
putting all that to the side why the
hell is the NEA chiming in on abortion
at all what do they have to do with this
issue they aren't teaching unborn
children all the children they deal with
are already born it is disturbing and
creepy that they are so in favor of
killing their future students but the
fact is that abortion should be
irrelevant because they're not they
don't have anything to do with it so why
are they making official statements on
abortion in the first place a doctrinal
statements about it really well
Alexandre De Sanctis in the article she
points out correctly that this is what
intersectional ism intersectionality or
whatever you call it is all about on the
Left where no issue is allowed to stand
on its own every everything is related
to everything else and you must
constantly prove your bona fides
constantly present your left-wing resume
to prove that you're in line with
everything they think about everything
you have to always the way they put it
is you have to prove you're an ally you
have to be an ally to all of the various
different victim groups and all the
special interests and everything and you
have to prove that by reciting the
doctrines of the left and that's what
that's what the NEA has become it's just
it's it's I don't know at what point we
can complain about this is one of the
things that annoys me because we as
conservatives we spend a lot of time
complaining about the state of the
culture the state of society so on and
so forth I complain about it - at what
point though do we say ok you know what
enough complaining I'm gonna step up now
and just and do something I'm just going
to I'm going to yes I realize that I
mean the schools are a mess you've got
there's a left-wing idea indoctrination
that goes on at what point do we say
okay in in rather than notice that fact
and continue to send my kids into that
environment and just whine about it
online at what point am I gonna say I'm
going to make a radical change even if
it's a change that requires an enormous
adjustment to my lifestyle it requires
enormous sacrifice I'm going to make
that change because it's my kids are
worth it at what point do we say that
now I know that there are people out
there who literally just cannot
homeschool it's just not an option
the public school is the only choice for
them it's the only thing they could do I
know there are people in that situation
single parents you know they have to
work so what are they going to do they
got and if they can't afford private
school or if there aren't any good
private and there are plenty of private
schools that charge you a lot of money
but in the end or no better than public
school so if you can't you know you got
a work can't afford a good private
school or there just aren't any good
ones in the area then what choice do you
have public school is it right and there
could there could be I'm sure plenty of
homes out there with with two parents
we're just economically financially they
both have to work at least right now in
order to survive so there are people in
that situation I have to say their kids
into public school unfortunately but I
think that's how we have to look at it
where public school is I'm not saying
it's it can't be an option for anyone or
that you're doing something objectively
morally wrong by sending your kid to
public school what I'm saying is I think
we have to look at it is as last resort
if if there is literally no other option
then we do that but if there is any
other option we take that other option I
think we have to look at it like that
and if we all looked at it like that
that I think there would be right now a
mass exodus from the public school
because there are
plenty of parents who send their kid in
the public school system even though
they really do have other options all
right okay this this is great I have to
I can't ignore
this representative Joyce Biddy is a
congresswoman from Ohio she's a Democrat
I believe she's 69 years old her name is
Joyce Beattie okay so she looks and has
the name of and is the age of someone's
grandmother which is great she's she's
I'm sure a wonderful grandmother but
that context is important so that you
can appreciate the comedy of what I'm
about to show you you see Joyce she
wants teens to stop vaping she thinks
that that vaping is bad and she wants
she wants people to stop doing it and so
she put out a tweet yesterday and the
tweet is supposed to encourage kids to
stop vaping but I'm not sure if it's
going to do that yet the tweet is a work
of art watch I'll put it up on the
screen look at this it it says it says
hey teens which actually let's stop for
a minute you're already on the wrong
foot if there if you begin a statements
with hey teens then they're already
Tooting you out okay they already think
you're out of touch and you're a nerd
it's just if you want to talk to teens
never address them as teens it's just
you should never do that pay teens all
right it says hey teens vaping isn't
fleek or fire fire emoji that's why the
state of Ohio launched my life my quit
to show you that you don't need fat
clouds to be radical 100 gee willikers I
mean that is one groovy tweet that tweet
really makes me want to raise the roof
that is I mean Joyce Beatty is da bomb
yo cowabunga no actually that that tweet
is it's it's a youth pastor on steroids
that is I imagine that's basically how a
youth pastor speaks after downing a
whole wine cooler a whole box of whole
but that's that's a youth pastor on one
box of wine right there it's incredible
and you know it goes back to a point I
made a few weeks ago I guess we give
Joyce Beattie some points for trying
or maybe we don't we are but it goes
back to a point I made we are just
making vaping seem even cooler by trying
to stop teens from doing it okay so when
you want to stop teens from doing
something you you need to be as you know
as inconspicuous as possible in your in
your aims especially if you're trying to
make the things seem less cool and you
have to remember that you as an adult
are not cool and so if you just come
charging into the room and say a teens
that's not cool let's do something cool
instead if you do that you it's not
gonna let you get whatever the thing is
you said is not cool you just increased
its cool points by about 50 you just
added 50 cool points to it you can't do
that Joyce has just made not vaping
she's made not vaping so uncool that now
I want to take it up and I'm an adult I
actually want to vape for the first time
because of that tweet I I now have the
the the sudden urge to vape now you know
if my kids came to me at the age of six
and said hey daddy I want to start
vaping I feel like I have to say well
okay you know I understand how you do
what you need to do because they just I
mean all right in fact this tweet is so
bad that I might require my kids to vape
it may be a requirement kids did you
vape today don't go to bed without
vaping finish your vape before bed it's
just that's that's bad that is bad stuff
all right I here's one other thing we'll
discussion I regret we have to have
today but we do every year as the
temperature rises we have this
conversation now and when I say we I
don't mean me but but society people we
have to hear in the summer that
air-conditioning is sexist I don't know
if you've encountered this yet but it's
a thing now and every summer you hear it
especially if you're online air
conditioning is a sexist conspiracy
against women apparently evidently and
this is one of the new frontiers of
feminism feminism of course in this
country is so privileged so frivolous so
stupid so silly that they are just it's
it's so desperate to finding a reason to
exist anymore that now they're focused
on this the fight against air
conditioning a feminist will say that
women you know tend to be less
comfortable in cooler temperatures which
is true they get colder easier yet in
many buildings and offices have a/c and
they set the AC very low and this makes
women chilly and therefore it is sexist
that's the argument I'm not making it up
that really is the argument the New York
Times published one of the yearly
required think pieces on the subject
with the title of do Americans need air
conditioning answer yes a staff writer
for The Atlantic Taylor Lorenz shared it
with her own you know shared it with her
followers and added her own little mini
rant to it this is what she says she
says air conditioning is unhealthy bad
miserable and sexist I can't explain how
many times I've gotten sick over the
summer because of overzealous a/c in
offices hashtag ban AC then she
continues dying at all the men in my
mentions having a literal meltdown
because I suggested raising office temps
a few degrees in the summer no amount of
AC on the planet will help men online
chill and then she continues like by a
fan you're not gonna die lol I should be
able to wear dresses in the summer and
not get hypothermia weird that making
women slightly more comfortable and
productive at work causes so many men to
have a mental breakdown and then her
rant continues there I like how she says
this was this was a staff writer at the
Atlantic by the way I don't know if I
mentioned that this is someone who has a
an actual job writing in in in media at
a supposedly you know prestigious
publication supposedly emphasis on
supposedly I like how she says you're
not gonna die lol and then the very next
sentence says she's going to get
hypothermia if you want
into a building in the summer that set
at 68 degree she's gonna get hypothermia
indoors in July yet she's mocking men
because they supposedly say they're
gonna die without a/c well well here's
the thing I feel a few things here
number one no the fact is you're not
gonna die from 68 degrees in indoors in
the summer you're not gonna get
hypothermia you're not gonna die you're
not gonna get sick it makes you select
she doesn't make you sick okay eight now
on the other hand you say oh you're not
gonna die yes you will people die from
the heat all the time you nincompoop
what'd he talk about
I mean just imagine how privileged you
have to be as a as a first-world er to
sit there zap you're not gonna die from
they eat meanwhile literally thousands
of people are dying from the heat every
single year across the world including
in this country you will definitely die
you can die from heat AC really does
saves lives save lives that's not an
exaggeration if you're an if you are
anti AC I mean just think about
especially in very hot areas somebody is
outside they they're on the verge of
heat exhaustion too much exposure to the
heat and then they go inside and it's
air-conditioned and they cool down I
mean that I I am sure that in fact many
lives have been saved because they were
on the verge of heat exhaustion and then
we're able to get into a cooler
temperature if you don't have any AC in
the world then there's not gonna really
be any cooler temperatures everything's
gonna be pretty hot and so it's gonna be
harder to recover from or stave off heat
exhaustion but if you are anti AC I have
to assume that either you're just
totally full of it and you're a
hypocrite and you claim to be anti AC
while you use AC all the time in
actuality which I'm sure it's probably
the case with Taylor here or maybe you
live in like Maine or something or you
know because I guarantee you that no
human being south of say New England
could possibly really be against air
conditioning it's just it's it's not
possible and if you go down to Texas or
Arizona
and this is just this is someone who's
never been south at all I mean there's
no way you could go South Texas Arizona
go anywhere and sell and still have this
opinion the idea of living without AC
down there is just utterly absurd of
course people did it for thousands of
years and people still do it today but
you know what people live without
running water people live without
plumbing people live without proper
hygiene
okay people live without washing their
hands or bathing for months on end I
mean that also if people live with
malnutrition people live without clean
water people live in a lot of different
ways but that's you know fortunately in
modern civilization we have improved on
some of these areas greatly and we have
made for better living conditions
healthier living conditions more
comfortable living with it living
conditions that will preserve preserve
your life in your health ac is one of
those modern inventions that is just
absolutely positive absolutely good and
there's no drawback it's just look I'm
all about criticizing modern society and
and and criticizing certain modern
innovations and inventions I mean you
want to talk about the internet for
example if you want to make an argument
that the Internet has really been a net
negative for mankind and we'd be better
off without it
then I would probably have to agree with
you even though I make my living on the
Internet
but AC is one of those things that no
that's just that is a net positive all
the way there's really nothing bad about
it
other than what it costs you to run it
and and that's all there is to it now as
for because I really want to address
this also okay what I've said so far if
you're a sane person you agree let's
move on to the more contentious element
of this debate as for the temperature at
the office okay here's the deal ladies
and I'm gonna man I'm mansplaining now
100% this is this is a man's planting
moment because I feel like as a man III
think there are some women Taylor being
one of them but not just Taylor who
maybe don't understand why men like to
turn the a/c down especially in an
office environment and I'll tell you why
and it goes like this you can always
put on a sweater okay you you can put on
a layer and you could bring a blanket to
work I mean you can do anything or just
just put on a sweater or don't you know
Taylor says Iowa I like to wear a dress
to work well it's great that you like to
wear that but if you're not comfortable
in it maybe wear something else okay you
you you can't dress like you're going to
the beach and then wine that the
temperature indoors isn't set to reflect
beach conditions I think 9 times out of
10 when you have a woman's eye oh it's
too cold in here you look at what
they're wearing it's like okay we'll put
on a little bit more clothing and then
you won't be as cold as like it's not
rocket science here hot people this is
this is the way it works cold people can
put on layers hot people can only take
off so many letters before they go to
jail so that's easy that's why that's
why in the summer with the AC the
hottest person gets priority because
they can't do much with their hotness
whereas you you really have is unlimited
I mean you could put on as many layers
as you want but probably if the AC is
set at 67 god forbid to and you're
really cold one layer is all it's going
to take and you'll be fine okay if you
need six layers because of 67 or 68°
then you really do have a medical you
need to go to the doctor there's
something wrong so that's all there is
to another thing to keep in mind men at
especially in an office environment are
often required to wear suits and if not
suits they they have to wear long pants
and all the times they have to wear long
sleeves and they might have to wear a
time it's pretty common in an office
environment you know business attire for
a man is long sleeves and long pants at
a minimum and oftentimes also a suit
depending on where especially if you're
in a place like DC is where a lot of
these complaints come from is these
privileged whiney women in DC so it's so
cold in here
yeah but if you go to DC where it can
get really hot in the summer and you
look around all the men are wearing
suits and they're not wearing suits
because they want to they're wearing
suits because they have
- if it's 105 degrees in DC you're gonna
see men walking around in jackets that
they have to wear it is a requirement so
yet again they are you know depending on
the office policy they have to dress
that they can't dress down any more than
they already are
whereas you as a woman you can I mean we
see this is one area I know that we have
this competition by oh you know who has
it worse as a gender women have to deal
with menstruation and child labor that's
true okay you do have that on us and and
and that is one difficulty that you have
that I do not envy and you know I'm very
happy that as a man I don't men straight
although you know we're told that maybe
it's possible that I could as a man
because who knows genders is a construct
anyway but as it stands right now you
know I have I cannot get pregnant I
don't menstruate I admit I'm happy about
that and I'm glad that I don't I'm sorry
that you are the one has to carry that
burden but you got to give us I mean
this is one area where you do have it
easier and that is when it comes to
formal attire or business attire I mean
you have so many options for what you
can wear and you can change here's the
main thing depending on the season you
can adjust your outfit to the season you
realize men can't do that we're not it
doesn't matter if it's if it's five
degrees or five hundred we have to wear
the same damn thing
so if we want to turn the a/c down a
little bit then it just why not just be
cool about it pun intended and and bring
a sweater to work leave it at your desk
okay or or wear a warm it just there are
so many things you can do about it
there's not a lot we can do and that's
all okay that's it all right
and don't say well you could always
bring a fan yeah well you know what a
fan just all that does is if it's hot
inside the fan just shoots hot air at
you faster it doesn't actually help so
the AC the thing with AC is actually it
actually creates cooler air which which
again
when it's summertime that's normal
people want it to be cooler inside when
it's 95 degrees outside all right very
important issue I'm glad that I was able
to spend 45 minutes on it approximately
all right
the emails I'm going to get from that
conversation oh my gosh all right this
is from Lisette Matt Walsh Oh at
gmail.com
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com
[Music]
this is from Lisette says hi Matt in
response to the anxiety issue brought up
in Tuesday's episode I don't think the
line about when it becomes a disorder is
that arbitrary anxiety becomes a
disorder when it affects your daily life
and your ability to function and do
basic tasks naturally all humans have
anxiety but they also have have healthy
coping mechanisms that allow them to
continue about their day for example
many people get anxiety about job
interviews but if you just don't show up
for any interview or never even apply
because of that anxiety then that's a
disorder right anyway that's just my
thought love your show you know we
talked yesterday about anxiety disorder
someone emailed Nast about it and I said
my yeah I think with with the so called
anxiety disorder it like with many
mental disorders it I think that we may
be dealing with a category error by
calling these things mental disorders
because they are a part of the normal
human condition and it just seems so
arbitrary where we draw the line and say
yeah okay well this amount of anxiety is
is normal but then if you have this
amount it's not normal
therefore it's a disorder who decides
where that line is drawn how do you
quantify it I mean where are we getting
any of this from it just seems totally
arbitrary now Liz Lissette says well no
if it if it negatively affects your
daily life that's where you drop the
line draw the line and yeah I got other
emails from people saying the same thing
it's the same thing I hear about ADHD
now I've said before eight I don't think
ADHD exists and what I mean by that is
what is what is ADH do you stand for
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
okay now people I think people who
exhibit those characteristics that we
label ADHD those people do exist that
personality type does exist
I am one of those personality types and
I and I know that I exist so that's how
I know that that exists my point though
is that it's not a disorder it is a type
it is just a type of person and in it's
okay to be that type it may be it may be
harder in some environments and may be
inconvenient at school but that doesn't
mean that it's a disorder I think the
disorder label that's what I'm taking
issue with and I think that that label
is subjective that's that it you want to
talk about social constructs well ADHD
is a social construct we have decided in
our society that those types of people
are just not easy to have around they
cause problems therefore it's a disorder
that's the way that that goes and I
think it's a a similar thing with you
know anxiety and depression some of
these other issues now the problem is
you say okay well if it affects your
life okay but of course it you know we
agree that everybody has anxiety right
and anxiety is always going to have some
kind of negative effect on your life
hey there can be scenarios where I guess
anxiety is good like if you have anxiety
about doing something dangerous and then
you don't do the dangerous thing that
was good but for the most part we all
have anxieties about things that you
know anxieties that cause us to do
things or not do things you know that
that have a negative impact on our life
okay we all we so that's that's all of
it just like with ADHD so well if you
get distracted it has a negative effect
on you and you're like well yeah of
course it has we're all negatively
impacted by we all have struggled paying
attention sometimes we all have times
where we have trouble sitting still and
that always is going to have a negative
impact on our life so my point is you
can't get around the fact that there is
going to be an arbitrary line somewhere
but because the line is arbitrary you
don't know where it is it could be
anywhere so we all have anxiety you
agree with that even though you didn't
say it I assume you agree that we all
have anxiety and we have all been
negatively impacted in our life by
anxiety
that's the case for everybody you're not
gonna find a single person on the planet
who that doesn't quality doesn't fit
under that umbrella so then what we're
saying is okay yeah everybody has
anxiety
everyone's negatively impacted by but if
you're negatively impacted this much
it's fine but if you're negative
impacted that much it's not fine so
there is somewhere there's like a there
is a somewhere there's a line somewhere
we're okay if you're negatively impacted
up to that line it's not a disorder but
if you cross over that invisible
arbitrary line that someone just placed
there and could place anywhere but they
chose to put it there then all of a
sudden it's a disorder it just it
doesn't it really doesn't make sense
and this is not we could say all the
time oh no it's a real disease this is
not how diseases are diagnosed okay if
you have cancer if you have diabetes if
you have any you know any any real
physical disease the doctor isn't going
to look and say oh well how is it
affecting your life or you know how much
of it do you have it's like that doesn't
if you have any amount of cancer it's a
problem now depending on how much chaos
you have how bad it is I might determine
how they treat it but it's there is no
healthy amount of cancer if you have
diabetes it doesn't really matter if it
affects how much it affects your life it
probably will affect your life
tremendously but the doctor isn't going
to get into well how much does it affect
your life okay well then you don't
really have it if you haven't you have
it it's only with mental disorders where
we get into this thing about does it
affect your life this much does it
affect it that much where is it where's
the equation and it's just I think that
is an indication that we are dealing
with something other than a physical
disease it is not the same thing
it just isn't it is a different sort of
thing that doesn't mean that I'm
trivializing it it doesn't mean that it
isn't real it doesn't mean that it isn't
it isn't serious it doesn't mean that it
that it doesn't you know affect your
life I'm not saying any of that I'm just
saying it's we are dealing with a
different category of thing it's
just not a disease it's something else
and I don't know why people get so and
I'm not saying you did Elizabet out of
shape about this topic and if you
question whether this or that supposed
to mean - sore derp is really a disease
people get very upset and I don't know
why like I'm not yes if I was sitting
here trivializing and say go you're fine
get over it okay I you should be upset
about that because that's that is
dismissive and stupid and I'm not saying
that if I'm just trying to figure out
what category it actually belongs to
that's not what's the big deal there
it's kind of like it's a different thing
not as serious but when we have this the
argument about and we've talked about
the show before about you know is is
this or that activity really a sport and
I've I've said that you know figure
skating is not a sport and people say oh
how dare you I mean how dare you insult
figure skating like not insulting it I
think it's an art form I think it's
beautiful I think it takes a lot of
skill and talent I think it's something
I could never do I think it's it's not
my cup of tea I don't really sit and
watch it but but I think it's an
incredible talent I have a lot of
respect for people that are good at it
so on and so forth I'm just saying it's
not a sport it's a it's a different
thing it's not a it's not a less
important thing it's not a it's not a
worse thing it's just a different thing
it's an art form in fact art forms are
you know arguably art is a is a is a
more elevated thing than a sport
arguably so that's the conversation here
when we talk about people that have the
ADHD personality when we talk about
people that struggle with anxiety which
by the way the fault I both with both of
those okay we talk about people that
struggle with depression so on what is
it what's actually going on I think it
is something deeper than mere chemical
reaction I think it is something more to
the core of a person and so really I
rather than trivializing it I'm doing
the opposite I'm saying you know it's
actually more serious than that it's
it's more than that
now with ADHD I would say that you know
in fact this is who a person is this is
this is how they are this is how they
operate this is how they think there's
nothing wrong with that in fact there
are advantages to it and so we need to
figure out how to harness that
personality and get those people into
you know a lifestyle into a line of work
wear it wear it wear it helps to be that
way
that's what I've been able to do we need
to encourage people to do that when it
comes to something like a depression and
anxiety I do think it's just my opinion
you know I think there are a lot of
people out there who are diagnosed with
anxiety who really they just have a
normal amount of anxiety I mean whatever
normal means I know I just said it's
arbitrary but but really they just I
think there are a lot of people that
just you know I do think there are
people who want essentially to have a
mental disorder maybe because it
provides an excuse for them you know
maybe in a sense it's become almost
trendy where people go around talking I
have anxiety people brownells brag about
it these days and so I think there are a
lot of people in that category I don't
know how many just I think there are a
lot but then I think there are other
people who really do and again it's
we're talking in court we're talking on
quantifying terms here so it's it's
difficult to do but whatever this means
there are people who have a lot more
anxiety than the average person people
who do struggle to live a normal life
and to go out in public and do normal
things because of their anxiety those
people do exist also not that I'm that
just like there are people with
depression you know I think there's a
lot of people diagnosed with depression
who actually are just kind of sad and
oftentimes for really obvious reasons
like something bad happened in their
life they're sad because of it they get
diagnosed as type depressed which which
actually causes them to never address
the real source of it think there are
people like that but then there are also
people who it's much deeper than that
much more serious the people in that
category I still think when we think in
terms of diseases we may be failing to
get to the heart
and the core of the problem I actually
think it's probably deeper than that
it's not just about chemicals I mean
think about it when you when you have
severe anxiety or when you're very
depressed there are things going on in
your mind right I mean really when you
when you talk about your anxiety you're
describing thoughts that you're having
and so are those thoughts really just
chemicals or is there something else I
mean is it totally illusory it's just
chemicals or miss firings like a
computer and I think sometimes when you
talk to a severely depressed person and
they start talking about life and I've
had this experience they start talking
about life they start talking about you
know their their their thought processes
a lot of what they say is true in a
sense so my point is they're not
hallucinating it's not like they're you
know it's not they're not crazy when
they talk about some of the inherent
sort of misery you find in life and some
of the meaninglessness of this and that
and the struggle to find meaning I mean
there's a lot of truth there so I think
one of the problems when we reduce it to
chemicals without at least have a
disease its chemicals we are totally
dismissing all of their thoughts and
saying oh no that's real let's all just
forget about all that I think there's a
lot of reality to it but we have to
figure out how to sort through it how to
harness it how to you know how to put it
in proper perspective all of those
things so it's a deeper issue that's my
play last thing I'll say on this topic
that I think there
for this stuff who should be on medicine
but maybe if you if you say to me and
people have said this to me about ADHD
now I think we shouldn't be putting kids
on that on medicine for ADHD at all
we should be putting kids on it we don't
know what it's doing to their brain it's
not fair to them but there are adults
who say listen you know you say it's not
a disease maybe it's not all I know is
that for me I take the ADHD medicine it
helps me at work it I enjoy life more I
just I like my life more when I'm able
to take this stuff and so that's why I
take it you know what I I think maybe
that could be a perfectly reasonable
reason to take something my point is
maybe it doesn't necessarily have to
actually be medicine for a real disease
but it may be it's just it helps you and
you like how it you know how it sort of
sorts through your thoughts and so you
take it so that now I think that that
approach could be abused and and you
know so it's it's we shouldn't always
just take anything because it makes us
feel good but that could be a perfectly
reasonable justification for taking
something for ADHD or anxiety where even
you say well maybe it's not a disease
but look it helps me okay not that it
matters if I give my blessing or not but
I do think that that could be a fine
reason all right this is from Luke says
hi Matt Luke here I hope you're doing
pretty much great I have a question for
you I hope you're doing pretty much
great okay and I need to start out with
a story of an unforgettable morning of
mine recently my wife and I woke up very
early to a bunch of loud chaos in my
boy's room my boys Troy and Ellie were
two and four I was about to grab my
shotgun but it sounded like it was just
them together and they were just having
a lot of fun too much fun after stepping
out of our bedroom and it confused days
I noticed that the front door was wide
open and our rabbits were released
outside of their pens and running around
that I walked towards to my boys room
and suddenly noticed the corner of my
eye on the table something was moving
all of our fish from our fish tank we're
lying on the dining room table still
flopping around gasping for water I then
proceeded towards my boys bedroom
thinking that I was simply in some
abstract nightmare and was curious as to
where the
Streamwood cut would end up I opened the
boys door they had opened their window
and the older son went outside and
literally threw all nine of our chickens
from the pen into their bedroom and shut
the window and they were chasing them
around in circles laughing hysterically
trying to catch them feathers were
everywhere and I mean everywhere along
with a mess from all nine chickens they
were they were they there were two eggs
on the ground - they froze looking at me
as if they would not live to see
breakfast I just stared and thought for
a minute about everything that had just
happened and told them to bring the
chickens out and I went to my bedroom I
just had to laugh without them seeing it
was all I could do they later told me
that they simply wanted to set all the
animals free to play so they did just
that so that leads to my question and
that is do you believe correctly that
pineapple belongs on pizza Thank You
Luke for that question and that setup
which I think was very necessary for me
to understand the full context of your
question about the pineapple and the
pizza and the answer to your question is
that of course the no fruit does not
belong on pizza period ever that's all
and I know you might say oh well well
tomatoes technically a fruit no it isn't
okay I don't care what the scientists
say tomato has been adopted into the
vegetable family it is a vegetable
vegetables and fruits these are social
constructs anyway and and no you
absolutely do not put pineapple and
pizza there is it's it's not that I
can't eat pizza with pineapple I mean I
can eat pizza with anything I can eat
anything period and if you if you give
me a pizza I'll eat it I don't care what
you put on it but it won't improve the
situation like I'm never gonna have a
slice of pineapple pizza and say to
myself oh I'm really glad they put
pineapple on this I'm never gonna say oh
I can't think of anything better they
could have possibly put on this thing
than pineapple there are literally
dozens of better options you went with
the worst possible option again I will
still stuff my fat face any five of them
but I'm not gonna like it alright that's
it for the show today thanks everybody
for watching Godspeed hey everyone its
Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin
show abused children they only become
when the left can use them for political
purposes if they can attack Trump's
attempts to secure the border or give
the Catholic Church a bad name or take
out a Republican candidate who did
something wrong but when it comes to the
persistent organized sexual abuse of
underage girls and boys the story always
dies let's keep an eye on this epstein
case and see where it goes on the Andrew
Klavan show
I'm Andrew Clavin